the first property is the commutative
property and just like you know your
parents are you you know you take a
commute right like you're driving your
car you're moving okay so when you think
of community you can think of moving and
I'll show you the property here there's
one for addition okay actually we'll do
the addition ones here and then there's
a property a community of property for
multiplication so we're gonna do for
both so basically in your book they
would show you something like this a
plus B equals B plus a so you can see
what they did is they commuted or they
moved the location of these two
quantities and now I'll give you an
example like 3 plus 4 equals 4 plus 3
that's pretty obvious right 3 plus 4 is
7 4 plus 3 is 7 they're equal and it's
the same thing for multiplication
they'll write the property like this a
times B equals B times a or you could
say 3 times 4 equals 4 times 3 12 equals
12
right so commute think about moving ok
commutative property now the associative
property think about who your friends
are who you associate with you know who
do you hang out with at school that's
your group right and so when you think
of the associative property think of
grouping so for example in your book or
in your class they'll show you something
like this a plus B plus C equals a plus
B plus C notice the order didn't change
like the commutative property but what
they'll show you is that they're
grouping or associating the first two
quantities and then over here they're
associating or grouping the last two
quantities so an example would be like 1
plus 2 plus 3 equals 1 plus 2 plus 3 so
I'm going to group the first two here
I'm grouping the last 2 I'm just
changing how I'm associating or grouping
but you can see this would be 3 plus 3
is 6 here we do 5 first plus 1 is 6 but
6 equals 6
so with multiplication we'll do the same
thing a times B times C equals a times B
times C it's just a matter of which ones
do you multiply together first so if we
do the same kind of numbers here 1 times
2 or do we do 2 times 3 first doesn't
matter this would be 2 times 3 is 6 this
would be 6 times 1 is 6 6 equals 6 you
get the same answer
so again commuting or think about moving
associating we're keeping the order the
same but we're grouping okay like
associating and now identity property
now when you look at the word identity
you think of what identical like the
same right like identical twins and so
for addition it's like this a plus 0
equals a see if you start with it you
end up with the identical quantity a an
example would be 3 plus 0 equals 3
anything plus 0 will be its identical
self so just think if you look at the
term it'll help you to understand what
it is same thing with multiplication but
this is more like a times 1 equals a so
if you take any number and you multiply
it by 1 you get the identical thing back
okay so with me so far we're memorizing
these commutative you move associative
you group but you don't change the order
like commutative identity you get the
identical quantity back so adding 0 you
get the identical quantity back
multiplying by 1 you get the identical
quantity back so all you have to do with
these properties is add on commutative
property of addition commutative
property of multiplication associative
property of addition associative
property of multiplication identity
property of addition identity property
of multiplication so you add on whether
it's 4 addition or multiplication now a
lot of students will say hmm isn't there
one for subtraction or division and
these properties only apply to addition
and multiplication
okay so inverse property inverses like
this so a plus negative a equals 0 so if
you take any number and you add the
negative quantity those are gonna undo
one another like there are they inverse
of each other they undo one another and
you get zero so if you walk four or
three steps and you walk backward three
steps that's like a negative three step
you're back to where you started you're
at zero so inverse is like undoing okay
and so this is the inverse property of
addition but the inverse property of
multiplication is a little bit different
it's 8 times 1 over a equals 1 so an
example would be like 3 times 1/3 equals
1 it's kind of like if you you know
multiply by 3 that inverse is 2/3
but dividing is like multiplying by the
reciprocal so anything if you do 1 over
that number when you multiply that you
get back one so with multiplication
getting back one is like undoing or the
inverse so we've got inverse property of
addition you get zero okay by adding the
opposite sign with multiplication you
multiply by the reciprocal and that
gives you back the number one so this is
the inverse property of multiplication
okay now the property of zero and the
property of negative one these just
apply to multiplication you're not to
worry about these for addition but the
property of zero is like this if we do
it symbolically a times zero equals zero
so five times zero equals zero basically
saying that the property of zero is
whenever you multiply by zero you get
zero okay and the property of negative
one is like this a times negative one
equals negative eight basically you take
any quantity and you multiply it by
negative one and you're going to get the
same number but the opposite sign